alexis poulain bonsoir je viens
d'énumérer les principales annonces de
jean castex notamment donc leur
confinement qui ne se justifient pas
selon lui un nouveau confinement se fera
je cite en ultime recours c'est
exactement ce qu'avait dit également
cette semaine
gadret la table de porte parole du
gouvernement c'est le choix de la
confiance mais pas de la contrainte
comment est-ce que vous accueillez cela
c'est en gros soyez responsables sinon
on confine c'est ça oui alors on voit
que ce soir les françaises sont très
gentils ils sont très respectueux ils
ont fait du bon boulot même pendant les
fêtes on remercie les soignants on
remercie les policiers ont remercié
profs ils sont là là on a vraiment un
exécutif qui fait merci les français on
est loin des 66 millions de procureurs
ou des français qui comprennent jamais
rien vraiment on est dans le l'instant
caresses c'est le moment où jean castex
va nous dire merci parce que on doit
continuer les efforts et évidemment 1re
confinement c'est le dernier recours et
c'est surtout maintenant devenu hors de
prix le quoi qu'il en coûte à toucher à
sa fin
c'est impossible de reconfirmer
d'ailleurs nos voisins vont vers le
déconfinement l'allègement que ce soit
en italie en espagne ou ailleurs
on est loin des mesures françaises qui
sont de toute façon apparenté à ce que
pourrait être un confinement
un couvre-feu à 18h les bars les
restaurants fermés les cinémas les
théâtres fermés les grandes surfaces
permet pas à part aller au travail
rentrée est encore allé voir à payer
maintenant tous est possible lancé l'une
des annonces de l'est jean castex ce
soir donc finalement je crois qu'il ya
là derrière la patte des cabinets de
conseils grassement payés par l'état
pour ne pas utiliser le mot confinement
mais utiliser finalement toutes les
ficelles de ce qui va être defacto un
nouveau confinement mais qui n'en est
pas un puisque on a le droit quand même
de prendre sa voiture de changer de
région de bouger l'avion ça devient
compliqué passer la frontière
gérald darmanin l'a expliqué c'est très
compliqué pour les frontaliers qui vont
passer des heures dans les bouchons
et voilà donc tout est fait en fait pour
éviter le gros mot qui est confinement
mais néanmoins les mesures aujourd'hui
on peut parler d'une vie normes
loin de là un couvre-feu à 18 heures
c'est quand même catastrophique pour les
commerces scandaleux puisque l'on se
fait verbaliser lorsqu'on fait des
courses après 18 heures au final quand
même un tour de vis d'annoncer si ce
n'est déjà envie de dire les
verbalisations qui ont augmenté de 53%
selon gérald darmanin depuis le week-end
dernier il est là finalement le tour de
vis et ça c'est c'est la menace pour ne
par confiner alors c'est même pas la
menace je crois que là on a affaire à
une stratégie délibérée
gérald darmanin est très fier de parler
de ses 53 % bld explosion de
contraventions 177000 ont été dressés
depuis le 15 décembre à 125 euros la
contravention sauf problème de liaison
avec avec alexis poulain peut être ce
qu'on peut rejoindre alexis pool ainsi
sa connexion revient on est en train de
débriefer avec lui notre éditorialiste
et annonce de jean castex
oui on a retrouvé alexis poulain vous
êtes là j'avais pas bougé on était en
train de parler des 53 % de
verbalisation supplémentaires depuis le
week-end dernier a annoncé par gérald
darmanin ministre de l'intérieur oui
alors c'est là qu'ils voient avec fierté
à la façon dont le ministre de
l'intérieur annonce cette explosion des
contraventions 177000 contraventions qui
ont été dressés depuis le 15 décembre à
125 euros la contravention ses 22
millions cent vingt-cinq mille euros qui
vont dans les caisses de l'état
on peut parler d'un impôt caché en
réalité ou d'un racket organisé quand on
a vu dimanche soir la façon dont les
policiers opérait c'est à dire qu'il
bloquait le périphérique et mais il
dressait des amendes aux automobilistes
après 18 heures on a eu aussi des
témoignages de français qui se faisait
verbalisé à 18h05 aux caisses des
supermarchés alors qu'ils faisaient
leurs courses c'est proprement
scandaleux et nous ont parlé d' impôt
caché parce que là il n'y a pas d'autres
raisons
c'est pas ça qui va contrôler finalement
la façon dont les français se comportent
puisqu'il se comporte bien si on écoute
ce qu'a dit jean castex
ils ont été très sages pour le jour de
l'an pour les fêtes il n'y a pas eu
d'explosion de nouvelles vagues les
français eh bien oui ils sont quand même
très responsable dans l'ensemble donc
que gérald darmanin va continuer oui
pardonnez moi un mois également
sur la vaccination je cite d'ici avril
nous aurons atteint l'objectif du
président de la république d'avoir
proposer la vaccination à tous les plus
de 75 ans volontaire jean castex qui a
annoncé également 1,7 million de
rendez-vous dans les jours à venir pour
une première injection
cet objectif atteint d'ici avril pour
les plus de 75 ans selon les mots du
premier ministre
est-ce que c'est suffisant pour
atteindre l'aude l'autre objectif fixé
par emmanuel macron cette semaine c'est
à dire de vacciner tous ceux qui le
souhaitent d'ici la fin de l'été
oui c'est évidemment qu'il va falloir
monter en puissance dans cet objectif de
vaccination à savoir ce qu'on appelle
vaccination est ce que c'est une dose ou
deux injections
combien de temps entre les deux
injections donc évidemment la première
phase qui était écrite qui était annoncé
c'était de vacciner les personnes en
ehpad et les personnes avec des
comorbidités lipsky est en train d'être
fait effectivement et jean castex était
très fier d'annoncer que même en janvier
les objectifs avaient été dépassés
puisque on était passé de 1,25 million
plutôt que d 1 million annoncé deux
premières injections donc là l'état fait
tout pour continuer avec en prenant en
compte également le problème des rendez
vous dont kiel il a aussi expliqué
qu'ils auraient davantage de rendez-vous
qui vont s'ouvrir pour pouvoir avoir
cette cette vaccination a rendu possible
à ceux qui le souhaitent
donc ça reste encore hypothétique que
tous ceux qui le souhaitent pourront
être vaccinés avant l'été à savoir les
annonces des vrilles raconte de lundi
soir mais clairement le gouvernement a
choisi la stratégie de mettre tout pour
le vaccin de faire tout le possible pour
que le vaccin ce la campagne de
vaccination soit un succès parce qu'il
en va finalement de la crédibilité
politique de l'exécutif avec le vaccin
astrazeneca qui arrivera donc samedi
également notamment pour les soignants
ce qu'a annoncé jean castex tout à
l'heure dernière question alexis poulain
sur leur confinement généralisée
à mayotte pour pour trois semaines
comment est-ce que vous accueillez cette
annonce alors clairement il y à une
inquiétude réelle au sein de l'exécutif
sur les variants notamment le variant
brésilien et sud africains parce qu'on
n'a pas assez de d'informations encore
sur la dangerosité de ces variants sur
leur résistance ou des eaux va au vaccin
et la cie les variantes deviennent
majoritaires et sont résistants aux
vaccins toute la stratégie qui mise sur
la campagne vaccinale tombe à l'eau avec
le danger d'avoir un virus plus
dangereux pour davantage de personnes
dans la population donc à mayotte
il a été vu que finalement le variant
brésil a commencé à circuler sans doute
beaucoup trop au goût des autorités
donc c'est le choix du confinement est
il ce choix du confinement encore une
fois il est toujours sur la table
il est certes un dernier recours mais
encore une fois nous vivons quasiment en
confinement
le couvre-feu à 18 heures le fait que le
télétravail va être proposée voir
imposer voir le multiplier la difficulté
de déplacement tous savent c'est que on
peut quasiment parler de confinement
donc donc mayotte ça ne m'étonne pas je
crois qu'aujourd'hui l'enjeu pour les
autorités c'est d'éviter la circulation
des variants parce qu'on est en train de
rejouer 2020 avec au lieu du coc vide 19
et bien les variants du coc u19 en 2021
merci alexis poulain pour avoir
débriefer avec lui mon direct sur rt
france les annonces de jean castex
d'olivier véran de gérald darmanin
d'elisabeth bornes également